Let's talk about some of the core fundamentals of Sequencer.
So the first question is, what is a Sequencer?
What is Sequencer?
So Sequencer is a non-linear editing tool inside of Unreal that allows us to assemble
content, whether it's content that's currently in our game or on our map, or to be able
to create spawnable assets, which we'll talk about here in just a second.
We can add audio.
We can add camera cuts.
We essentially can create, for lack of better terms, a complete feature film within the editor
itself without ever having to go outside and use any other DCC programs.
Additionally, as it relates to games, we can actually use Sequencer to create in-game
cutscenes.
We can use it for loading screens.
We can use it for player showcases.
Again, Sequencer is not just about creating film, but basically allows us to assemble
all of these components in a, for lack of better terms, a pre-scripted way to get the
visual results that we want.
Now one thing to cover is that we're going to be talking about terminology about film,
sequence, shots, nested sequences, master sequences, et cetera.
Fundamentally, all of these are going to be using a sequence from inside of the
editor.
And it's important to understand that a sequence, you don't have to have a different type
of sequence or a different type of piece of content to create these.
We're going to be using the same sequence and essentially it's just a container.
Really the important part to remember is how you use that container that really changes
its function, which again is going to allow us to create shots, sequences, graduated
sequences, master sequences, and then finally everything propagated up into what we'll
just effectively call our film.
A couple pieces of terminology that you need to understand when it comes to Sequencer is
we can target content that's already in our map.
So for example, if we have certain interactable components or we have certain NPCs, characters,
we will call those possessables.
And essentially it just allows us to target whatever those assets are and inside of our
Sequencer make changes, whether it's translation, attribute changes, et cetera.
Fundamentally speaking, those are already in our world, which brings us to our second
type, which is a spawnable.
Level assets really only exist inside of the level sequence.
And we know that identified by this lightning bolt icon.
So essentially what we could do is we could have our world that's built for our game
that our player is playing through.
And we have an in-game cut scene, which we'll actually build here in just a little
bit.
And in that cut scene, we may have an NPC that exists only for that cut scene.
So rather than have that character just floating somewhere in the world during our sequence
during playback, we can have that object spawn in.
And then when the sequence is done, unload and spawn out.